Hola y bienvenidos a la entrevista de
France 24 Bienvenidos a Munich donde
tiene lugar la conferencia anual de
seguridad nuestro invitado de hoy es el
presidente de Finlandia shaoli ministop
Muchas gracias por estar con nosotros
señor presidente gracias por la
invitación llevamos un año de guerra en
Ucrania
cree que si Vladimir Putin no es
derrotado en Ucrania irá más lejos y por
lo tanto Finlandia podría ser un
objetivo prioritario para él
si nos fijamos en lo que Putin y otros
rusos han estado diciendo
durante décadas
y siempre se ha concentrado más en
Ucrania
hay una especie de elemento histórico
que es que la madre Rusia
tienen su regazo un área más amplia que
solo Rusia
así hemos aprendido a conocer a Rusia
pero Finlandia en realidad no forma
parte de ese grupo
sin embargo si nos imagináramos que
Putin tendrá mucho éxito en Ucrania
bueno puede ser que su apetito esté
creciendo
en lo que respecta a Finlandia no
tenemos miedo
estamos bien despiertos y esa es la
posición que Finlandia tiene
que siempre ha tenido porque tenemos
algunos recuerdos muy oscuros de siglos
y una frontera muy larga Sí hay una
frontera muy larga usted conoce a
Vladimir Putin desde que fue elegido por
primera vez hace una década
lo llamó en mayo para decirle que lo que
había hecho
había provocado un cambio de posición en
Finlandia que Finlandia se convertiría
en miembro de la otan qué le dijo Putin
de hecho ya lo dije públicamente
le dije mirese al espejo
usted fue quien causó esto
y quise llamarlo Solamente porque no soy
de los que se esconden sigilosamente en
una esquina
fui claro Al decirle que íbamos a
unirnos a la otan
y se lo tomó con bastante calma de hecho
sin amenazas sin amenazas también dijo
públicamente que no cree que sea una
amenaza
sino que Finlandia cometió un error
Esa fue su respuesta
pero sin duda antes y después su gente
ha estado diciendo que si vamos a la
otan Ellos tendrán que responder de
alguna manera a eso eso significa tal
vez más presencia militar en la frontera
eso se está viendo
cómo tienen ahora alrededor de los
países bálticos y ese tipo de cosas pero
por ahora no hemos visto ninguna señal
de eso porque parece que necesitan sus
tropas en otros lugares
en 2007 Vladimir Putin vino aquí
pronunció un discurso en el que criticó
la expansión de la otan diciendo que era
una amenaza
los países occidentales pensaron bueno
quizá tenga quejas pero sigamos adelante
al año siguiente entró en Georgia y
luego en Ucrania en 2014 usted conoce a
Vladimir Putin ha pasado tiempo con él
acaso usted y otros en occidente lo mal
interpretaron totalmente
tal vez
pero sin duda condenamos inmediatamente
la operación de crimea
operational
y la entrada en el donbas en 2014
después comenzó el proceso de Minsk
Roses
y creo que al menos durante un par de
años muchos creyeron que esto pondría
fin a la crisis
y que se podría llegar algún tipo de
acuerdo
pero en el proceso de
la culpa sólo hubo conversaciones que no
dieron ningún resultado
nuestra esperanza que funcionara
disminuyó
creo que muchos de nosotros
comprendimos que la cuestión ucraniana
es una cuestión abierta para los rusos
pero ahora es una guerra abierta es
decir nadie predijo hace un año que
veríamos lo que estamos viendo incluido
usted mismo decir vale esperábamos que
no fuera así nos dimos cuenta que no iba
a ninguna parte es diferente a que Rusia
invada Ucrania sí debemos tener en
cuenta que ya a finales de 2021
escuchamos especialmente a los servicios
de inteligencia estadounidenses decir
intelligence
que estaban seguros de que Putin Estaba
preparando un ataque
si tuve algunas conversaciones con el
presidente biden en diciembre y enero
y todavía había Esperanza
al menos algún tipo de esperanza de que
se pudiera evitar
y estuve llamando a biden y a Putin y a
biden y a Putin
pero nada ayudó los rusos seguían
diciendo que no iba a atacar
el presidente dijo que no debería haber
compromisos territoriales con Rusia esto
significa que la idea de que crimea
podría ser un punto de negociación Como
algunos países occidentales han dicho
está totalmente descartada creo que el
presidente tiene muy buenas razones para
defender su territorio
Y ese es realmente su deber y su tarea
Emmanuel majó el presidente francés dijo
hace dos meses que Europa debía
plantearse dar garantías de seguridad a
Rusia En aquel momento fue criticado por
los líderes ucranianos y también por
usted Usted dijo que no era el momento
desde entonces Mako ha dicho que tenemos
que asegurarnos de que Rusia sea
derrotada aquí en Múnich dijo que está
claro que ahora no es el momento de
dialogar que nos espera una larga guerra
crea que el presidente francés y en
cierta medida el canciller Alemán han
recapacitado sobre esta cuestión que no
es el momento de intentar llegar a un
compromiso computing
en primer lugar
Considero que lo más importante es que
tanto el presidente macrón
como el canciller soles tengan la
posibilidad de hablar con el kremlin
son parejas Alguien tiene que hacerlo
algún día
y es importante mantener abierta esa
posibilidad
positiva
luego en cuanto a lo que dijo el
presidente macron sobre las garantías de
seguridad
mi respuesta fue que sí
que si Rusia
puede dar garantías de seguridad a sus
vecinos con la misma credibilidad que
nosotros Claro que sí
también está la cuestión del armamento
enviado tardíamente por occidente según
el presidente zelensky vimos el debate
sobre el sistema de defensa aérea sobre
los tanques Finlandia va a enviar
algunos tanques tanques leopard según
Tengo entendido a Ucrania cuando y
cuántos
en primer lugar le hemos dado ayuda
armamentística Ucrania
no se puede hacer más de lo que ha hecho
Alemania
y no hemos dicho abiertamente Qué tipo
de armamento estamos dando
porque no nos gustaría que nuestro
vecino leyera lo que tenemos y lo que
nos queda y lo que hemos dado
he dicho sobre el proyecto
que si hay cooperación europea Finlandia
participará en ella
pero tenemos que tener en cuenta que
Finlandia es el único país que posee
tanques que no es miembro de la otan
tiene una frontera muy larga
y así que nuestra Espera es limitada
aviones de combate buena idea es una
pregunta abierta ahora no tengo una
opinión al respecto veamos cómo
evoluciona
usted mencionó la otan obviamente lo que
también ha cambiado es que Finlandia y
Suecia están ahora a la espera de ser
aceptados en la otan son los dos países
no han ratificado este proceso el
primero es un guía y el segundo Turquía
durante muchos meses Finlandia y Suecia
habían dicho que entrarían juntos y
punto
Ahora parece que ha cambiado en los
últimos días
que como Turquía tiene más objeciones
hacia Suecia
Finlandia podría entrar primero
es eso lo que está pasando señor
presidente
de hecho durante mucho tiempo Turquía ha
estado diciendo que Finlandia está cerca
de ser aceptada y que Suecia
not y a veces incluso han dicho que
podrían aceptar a Finlandia
pero inmediatamente después oímos otra
voz de Turquía
también nos pone algunas condiciones
lo que ha ocurrido es que erdogan
ha dicho más abiertamente que Finlandia
podría ser aceptada
si no comete los mismos errores que
Suecia
tenemos un entendimiento total con
Suecia en el sentido de que ambos
queremos trabajar
that
para que los dos seamos miembros lo
antes posible pero ya no juntos eso ha
cambiado
tenemos nuestro pleno entendimiento y
Turquía tiene su propio entendimiento
digamos que si Turquía inicia el proceso
para ratificar a Finlandia
deberíamos rechazarlo
eso sería como retractarnos de la
solicitud
[Música]
es una posición difícil
pero Antes hubo conversaciones o
iniciativas de Turquía diciendo que
Finlandia debería expresar que queremos
separarnos
desvincularnos de Suecia
está diciendo que eso es lo que va a
hacer
no lo vamos a hacer No
si nos preguntan si lo queremos o si nos
negamos nuestra respuesta es muy clara
está en sus manos
Ya hemos indicado nuestra voluntad
solicitando la adhesión
Entonces esto debería resolverse pronto
hace poco dijo que esperaban que ambos
países fueran admitidos antes de la
próxima cumbre de la otan programada
para Julio
sigue siendo una esperanza realista O
creo en eso cree en eso sí Pero ha
intentado hablar con el presidente
erdogan Para convencerlo de que acepte a
Finlandia
no he hablado con él porque realmente
quiero seguir con Suecia usted
hicimos la solicitud y normalmente
cuando uno hace la solicitud
no tiene que ir detrás haciendo
preguntas o pidiendo que lo acepten
estamos esperando su respuesta
presidente ni ministro de Finlandia
Muchas gracias por participar en la
entrevista de France 24
y gracias a ustedes por haberla visto
[Música]